what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with sins of sinister and I
love this story oh my God now one of the
things to remember right these three
number ones that we've done so far
storming the Brotherhood nightcrawlers
which is coming out later this week and
then this one immoral X-Men this all
takes place in the first 10 years the
number twos that are going to be coming
out take place during 100 years and then
the final three issues take place at 1
000 years so again 10 years 100 years
thousand years so during this 10-year
window which is really when the X-Men
first start taking over everything and
conquering the world that we basically
have an attempt by really Nick Fury and
I love that I'd call them his Howling
Commandos but basically what's left of
Shield launching a strike force against
Westchester in order to take down the
ability for the X-Men to effectively
control everybody right the cerebro
satellite in the sky that kind of
monitors everything that everybody has
going on all the time now one of the
crazy things about this is that it's
Nick Fury in them begin to launch their
mission and they jump out of this window
their brains shut down and they smash
into the ground and die only for us to
find out Xavier had basically screwed
with their heads this is nuts man it's
one hell of a way to open a comic book
to be honest with you guys I love it
like I absolutely love the way this was
done now the funny thing about this is
that this is literally just Xavier
saying another cell's gone and that's
what's cool about this because what it
shows us is that when it comes to these
different Rogue factions that are trying
to work against the X-Men in order to
stop them from Conquering the world that
some of them have the ability to dodge
the influence of Professor Xavier in
other telepaths now that's not unheard
of anybody who's been reading X-Men for
any real measure of time knows and
honestly I would say using Tech to
overcome the power of telepaths that
didn't really become a big thing until
the 90s you saw people doing it during
the Run of Chris Claremont back during
the 70s and the 80s but in truth the 90s
is when like everything in Marvel was
like super high octane fast paced and
like all all kinds of high-tech stuff
and so during this time it was not
uncommon to see people overcome the
power of telepaths using technology size
scans is what they would or at least a
size Shield is what they would call them
but the cool thing about this is that
Xavier having done this he actually kind
of starts to cry because even even
though what they're doing is quote
unquote in the eyes of the X-Men
bringing about a kind of peace to the
world that otherwise wouldn't exist it
still brings them a lot of Anguish to
know that there's somebody just wiping
people out and his stance is really more
like why can't they just succumb to our
Dream now it's kind of a funny thing
because depending on where you stand
morally you can kind of take one side of
the other right like Xavier tried to do
the dance he tried to do the whole thing
where it's like let's work together guys
and Humanity didn't want to do it so the
response of Xavier is well if you don't
want to do it willingly then we will
make you right we will make you accept
our existence now the undercurrent here
and it's one of the things to keep in
mind Sinister isn't really controlling
all of them but they are operating more
based on what Sinister would do as
opposed to anything else and we'll talk
a little bit more about that is because
that'll be a main focal point as we get
through this but unlike Xavier who still
maintains his Humanity Emma Frost
doesn't care and that's one of the
things Emma Frost has always been
cold-blooded and this this comic is
actually just gonna lay Emma Frost bear
not literally but you are going to see
like Emma Frost for who she is and
really just how cunning and dark she can
be and so it's really kind of a funny
thing because what ends up happening
here is you have a quiet counselor or at
least the quiet counsel that's brought
together by Emma Frost and one of the
things they initially do is they kind of
ask the question of Hope Summers why do
you have a cybernetic arm now the reason
why I Hope Summers does this is because
it's paying tribute to Cable remember
cable's not dead but he defected from
the X-Men and he joined Storm's
Brotherhood and is kind of doing his
thing at this point in time working
against the attempt of sinister to
conquer everything now the reason why
this matters and we covered it but truth
to tell we might go back and rework all
that mid-2000s X-Men stuff after
decimation but one of the things that
happened here is that after decimation
when all the mutants lost their early
like 98 of the mutant population lost
their powers due to the action of
Scarlet Witch Hope Summers was the first
mutant born after that happened now it
did turn into a kind of cat and mouse
game where the mutant Bishop was trying
to kill hope cable was trying to keep
her safe so literally cable was just
taking hope through time they were
jumping around the time stream and
Bishop was chasing after them but the
important thing is that hope is viewed
as the Messiah but the fact that she was
raised by Cable in a lot of ways she
sees cable as her father this is even
doubly important because of the fact
that her parents were killed when she
was a baby so she never actually knew
her parents Cable's the only Father
Figure she's ever known so that's why
you have such a strong father-daughter
bond between the two of them but the
thing about this and what's really kind
of interesting here is you switch over
to Sinister now Sinister again with his
diamond with a diamond on his head
remember he's one of four sinisters that
exist out there and none of them seem to
be aware of the others but what is
important here and what we really what
we saw at the end of the sins of
sinister one shot is that what he was
doing was cloning Mora mchaggard so he
could basically kill her if he needed to
reset the time stream because that's her
power and then he would basically remind
himself everything that was going on and
then restart this attempt to conquer the
world in case something went awry the
problem with this and as we know now
from the storm and the Brotherhood comic
stormwater forces stole the cloning lot
they stole the secret lab of sinister
and so what he's really trying to do
here is figure out what comes next
because without the ability to kill
Amora McTaggart and reset the time
stream he's stuck in this timeline until
whatever degree it plays out now one of
the other other things that's kind of
funny here is that when he teleports
back to just one of his safe havens he's
got those all over the world but when he
teleports back to one of them he's
basically got a clone of himself he's
not overly intelligent it's really just
a way for sinister to just bounce ideas
off of himself but one of the things he
makes a comment on is that he might go
meet with dark Beast now he here's the
thing I didn't even know dark beasts
existed anymore maybe I'm missing
something but as far as I'm aware dark
beasts has been out of Marvel Comics for
ages if he is here that's kind of a cool
thing for those of you guys who don't
know the significance of that back in
the 1990s Marvel had a comic called The
Age of Apocalypse which was a really
really fun and amazing comic book story
if you were a fan of the villain
apocalypse and even like everybody else
in Marvel it was just really cool the
way it was handled the important thing
here is that in that reality instead of
Beast being the more jovial member of
the X-Men who was like the Science Guy
slash cheerleader so on and so forth in
the Age of Apocalypse he was twisted
like he was really really twisted and he
would perform like gruesome experiments
on people that's how he earned the name
dark beast but when the Age of
Apocalypse timeline was ended when that
timeline was destroyed dark Beast was
one of a precious few number of
characters which included oh my God
Holocaust he made it out God I am God I
loved his character oh oh my God he was
amazing one of the one of the best
characters from the 90s that you've
never heard of if you never grew up
reading Marvel Comics of the 1990s he
was cool he was a really really cool
concept of course X-Man Nate gray also
escaped the timeline I think sugar man
did as well I don't know of anybody else
that made it out but the important thing
here is that dark Beast made it out of
the timeline and just kind of existed in
Marvel for a little while so again I'm
not 100 sure of dark Beast is here maybe
he is but regardless it is a cool little
reference right to the potential fact
that he is here but at the end of the
day Sinister comes to the realization
that only he can really trust himself to
get out of that because what he's done
is he's created a kind of backup plan
this idea at least under normal
circumstances is that he had what was
called The Inferno protocol which was
literally a doomsday button he would
just smash this button and it would kill
everybody under his control and then in
turn he could just go and reactivate the
timeline if he needed to but the reality
here is that doomsday button is in a
secret lab so literally any option he
has to destroy these guys guys and one
Fell Swoop is all basically gone so he's
got to do it piece by piece and so he
ends up showing up in the room of Emma
Frost while she's sleeping with what's
basically a lethal injection goes to
take her out only for the needle to
break and that's what we end up finding
out it's Emma Frost's inner Diamond form
more so than that the reason why the the
needle broke on her skin is because she
looked like she was in her normal form
but she wasn't and what's actually been
happening here is she's been holding
Jason Wingard prisoner in her own room
in order to basically trick anybody who
comes in there into believing that she's
just in her normal form she literally
keeps him hopped up on amphetamines all
the time the guy stays awake all the
time or really just kind of sleeps
during the day but like stays up all
night long in order to ensure that she's
protected lest he fails to do his job
and then pays the price which would
likely be psychic torture and then
probably not being able to spend the
night with him a frost anymore so the
thing about this in and what's really
crazy here
is that Emma Frost realizing what's
going on ultimately ends up attacking
Sinister or at least traveling back to
capture Sinister once Sinister teleports
away now what's funny about this is that
in response not only has Sinister been
combining the powers of different
mutants into Chimera he's also been
combining them into weapons so he
literally has this gun that he uses that
basically combines the power of Banshee
and Cipher in the sense that because
Cipher can speak any language he
basically uses the gun to blast Emma
Frost with a Sonic Blast but the power
of Cipher allows the gun to decipher
exactly what frequency Emma Frost
Diamond form is at so that it can be
broken and that's kind of the crazy
thing is because he literally shatters
her arm and there's kind of a brief
reprieve here because one of the things
that had gone on here is Sinister had
come to the realization that if he
really is going to try to take over the
world and he's going to use the X-Men to
do it and intended to keep them under
his control it was only a matter of time
before somebody was able to kill them
off and so what he did or at least what
the X-Men seemed to do was develop the
Logan patch much like a nicotine patch
where the Logan patch does is it
literally just kind of keeps your blood
filled with Logan's healing factor and
so when Emma Frost reverts back to her
human form her arm regrows so again it's
cool I love that like Marvel is kind of
taking all these little tidbits from all
these characters and just combine them
into just this incredibly amazing story
and so literally when when Emma Frost
heals herself it's only a matter of time
before she destroys Sinister so Sinister
pulls out yet another Ace in the Hole
and unleashes the Cyclops Chimera
basically these different people out
here who are are effectively sinisters
rebranded version of the nasty boys they
were a team as Sinister had back in the
day they really gained their prominence
through an X-Men the Animated Series is
well like they became the most popular
but they were kind of like a sinister's
second version of the Marauders more or
less but the nasty boys were kind of
like his own henchmen but what he's done
here is he's taken the optic blast of
Cyclops and combined them into other
people for example Groot seemingly has
the ability to shoot optic blast out of
his eyes and other parts of his body
which I'm not gonna lie it's kinda dope
like to be honest with you guys like
that's pretty awesome but literally it's
it's nuts because somebody like Ruckus
for example his eyes have been turned
into an optic Blaster the ability to
shoot optic blast but because the power
of ruckus was to emit a concussive
scream from his mouth that what would
happen is an optic blast was attached to
his mouth which seemingly amplify
amplifies the power of the optiblast so
again it's cool the way this was done
and it's really like Emma Frost as she
starts to manipulate these guys issues
like I know Cyclops inside and out and
in fact I was in love with Cyclops for
the longest time and what she says is
like there's no version of Cyclops that
exists out there that I cannot
manipulate that I cannot somehow trick
into fighting himself in some capacity
so literally using her telepathy she
gets into the mind of the nasty boys and
they all start attacking each other and
then she has like this amazing speech
right she says power is not what you are
power is what you do true Queens are
self-made not appointed and whether
those who bestow the titles are Gods
scientists or monarchs Emma Frost kneels
to no one and everyone kneels to me I am
the Divine Emma Frost and you've never
been higher than dying red-faced before
me it's pretty awesome because here's
the thing Emma Frost is one of these
characters where like she exists in
Marvel and she does some stuff sometimes
but she's never quite gotten her do the
way that she deserves and I'm still
waiting for a story that Marvel does
where Emma Frost is elevated to this
massive prominence because let's be
honest with ourselves during Civil War
they established that Emma Frost is more
powerful than Professor Xavier so it's
only a matter of time before Marvel
could write a story and it would
legitimately be believable where Emma
Frost either conquers the world or Kills
the Marvel universe or something like
that because she's an Omega Level
telepath what would be Thai the poor
soul that crosses Emma Frost with
nefarious intent right it's just it's
amazing like the way the way her
character functions but she ultimately
overpowers uh Nathaniel Essex and then
what he does is he reveals to her that
with these Chimera that he's created
where he can combine two powers that
given his research he's developed the
ability to put five powers in one
individual person now imagine that for a
second because when you look at
characters like Hope Summers who's an
Omega Level mutant and has the ability
to duplicate the powers of anybody she
meets and then presumably hold on to
those Powers forever or somebody like
Rogue who can touch a person and then
absorb their Consciousness or at least
in the Years leading up to the heckatome
storyline where she could actually
absorb multiple Powers into her own body
right like that that makes them a force
to be reckoned with and that's what
sinister's talking about creating here
the most powerful mutants to ever exist
in the history of the Marvel Universe
it's an astronomical situation right and
so Emma Frost realizing not only that
this could be done but she could
actually have it done to herself she
comes to this realization and even when
Sinister says you're all going to end up
Waging War against each other right like
absolute power corrupts absolutely
you're all working together now but it's
only a matter of time before those eyes
have compromised turn into eyes of envy
and you all start looking at each other
like well when are they going to make a
move against me and paranoia sets in and
you destroy yourselves but Emma Frost
looking at this comes to the realization
that if she's able to attain the right
combination possibly before anybody else
does she can take over the world she
could kill everybody and she could
literally conquer the world on her own
and there'd be no one to stand in her
way and so what she does is she convenes
a meeting of the quiet Council and then
gives them a kind of telepathic brief on
everything that's transpired of course
probably leaving out a few details
involving her own machinations and then
ask the question do we allow Nathaniel
Essex to continue with his experiments
or do we kill him or possibly even
submit him down to the to the great
chasm right to the abyss and the result
of the quiet Castle the verdict is we
let him continue so they welcome him
back into their ranks but sinisters on a
short leash and while Emma Frost doesn't
say it in so many words the reality is
that Nathaniel Essex days are numbered
right like once he finishes this unless
he's able to present an even better
scenario unless he's able to basically
provide himself or prove himself as a
person that has any kind of contribution
That Matters To The Quiet counsel if he
can't do that they're going to take him
out right and as we know from sins of
sinister the one shot they ultimately do
so it's a really really cool situation
but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end let
me know what you guys think about since
the Sinister man because I am loving
this story and I will catch you all
later
peace